[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar caught in the act tracking the
emergence and divergence of sars kobe 2
through statewide testing and sequencing
i am kayleigh bach of labyrinths and i
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinths and brought to
you by sql
to learn more visit sql.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
the live q a portion of this webinar
will be enabled until 10 minutes after
the hour or until there are no further
questions
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speakers
dr joseph c miller co-founder and chief
scientific officer of sequel
incorporated
and dr frank a middleton professor and
director of the molecular analysis core
at suny upstate medical university
dr miller and dr middleton you may now
begin your presentation
thank you for the introduction
my name is joe meller i'm the co-founder
and chief scientific officer here at
seekwell
to tell you a little bit about our
company we are a genomics technology and
product development company we create
products to help our customers with a
variety of critical bottlenecks in their
high throughput ngs workflows
our goal is to make
sequencers easier and more efficient
for high large-scale demanding genomics
workflows
and one of the
key problems in many of these
applications is multiplexing
our plex-well product which you'll learn
about today in the application to covert
19 genomics is designed to address a
variety of different multiplexing
problems where users are trying to run
sometimes up to hundreds or even
thousands of samples at a single time on
an illumina sequencer what plex will
allow these users to do is to take those
samples through a quick and efficient
workflow
and pool them together and run them
in cases
involving
single cell rna seq or whole genome
sequencing amplicon plasmid sequencing
and again as we'll learn about today uh
with our speaker uh covet 19 viral whole
genome sequencing one of the key
technical features of placebo which
makes it very powerful for this approach
is the ability to normalize varying
amounts of dna going into the workflow
and produce highly uniform pools of
sequence ready library material
as we all know over the past two years
kovid 19 has presented a wide variety of
challenges and one of the ways that the
scientific community has responded
remarkably to this is in finding new
tools that can help us
understand and track and respond to the
challenges of the pandemic and
sequencing has certainly been a part of
that
one of the commonly uh i think
emerging uh trends and especially the
last year is is our ability to track and
uh and observe and of course uh predict
when certain variants are going to
emerge
and and and be able to see them in real
time which again uh professor frank
middleton will talk about more uh in a
little bit
um with plex well we've been able to
support this application by taking
advantage of tools that the community
developed such as the arctic multiplex
pcr protocol
to allow again for very efficient high
level multiplexing
again some cases hundreds or thousands
of samples
i encourage you to go to our website if
you're interested in learning more about
uh how our products support this
application uh and again uh it's been
very
exciting and rewarding for us to be able
to
help users who in many cases have not
set up a workflow at this level of scale
to be able to run
assays that can support high throughput
codewood sequencing
so with that i will conclude my
introductory remarks here again um we're
really excited today to introduce our
speaker dr frank middleton frank is a
professor of neuroscience and physiology
at suny upstate
university in syracuse
frank's lab studies a variety of
different things especially in the area
of
neural genetics and biomarker discovery
for neural disease
and he has really pioneered a number of
techniques in the use of next generation
sequencing
for these methods
one of the areas that frank's lab has
studied was the use of saliva based
tests which
turned out to be incredibly powerful
as we have seen now over the past couple
years for uh uh performing uh covet 19
testing and sequencing and frank will be
uh i'm sure telling us about that here
today
so without further ado again my pleasure
to introduce dr frank middleton um yeah
again frank we're looking forward to
your talk and uh
the floor is yours thanks
greetings everyone
thank you for the kind introduction joe
and thank you also for the opportunity
to share with this audience the results
of the work that we've been engaged in
over the past two years as this
endemic has challenged us in ways that
we couldn't have imagined
just two years ago
so i'll very pleased to describe to you
how we've utilized a particular
sequencing platform to leverage
the samples that we were
able to collect on a statewide basis in
a very large
fashion
to be able to monitor the divergence of
this
virus
that we've all come to know too well
as it's challenged us again and again
with
increasing surges and we're going to
talk about our journey through that
process and how it all began
if we think back
just two years ago
march 2020
that's when i became very involved in
developing new
tools to test for the presence of source
code 2
in human samples
there simply weren't enough
pcr tests that have been approved for
mass use in the united states
part of the blame
does
rest on the shoulders of the u.s
government which declined to utilize
tests that have been developed and
approved in other countries
and therefore it set us on a very
different time course
over the first few months of 2020
while the cdc was working on fine-tuning
a test that they rolled out eventually
the virus likely spread
in an insidious fashion undetected
throughout
parts of the united states
eventually when the test came out
it was obvious to all those involved in
any type of diagnostic testing
that this test used excessive amounts of
reagents it was not optimized
and
one example would be to look for the
virus
you had to do pcr reactions in different
wells in a 96 well plate
and you had to look for a human product
and another well
so you were using three or four
different wells in a pcr plate instead
of one
this meant a 96 watt plate
used for pcr wouldn't be able to screen
90 or more samples at a time
but
a much lower number in the 20s
this created delays
the tests also suffered from poor design
that didn't control for stray signal
it simply wasn't the case that the
primers and probes that had been
developed would always show no signal
when there was nothing in the well
except water
you could get late amplification curves
whenever the primers and probes were
combined together
this meant
the test lacks
low end sensitivity
and
contributing to that was the lack of the
control over dna contamination
the primers that have been ruled out
for use on the human or the host
reference gene
didn't have an intron sequence between
them that means human dna would be
detected just as readily as human rna in
the sample
and could lead to false negative
results
and these problems
combined
to delay the rollout of testing at the
scale that was needed
it was also the case that the only tests
approved for use
were those involving deep nasopharyngeal
swabs which required a healthcare
provider to perform
so what we recognized
in march
was that we wanted to be able to have
higher throughput methods that use less
reagents
that had less
possibility of false positive or false
negative rates we wanted to be able to
test people remotely potentially do
collections while they were still at
home
we wanted those samples to be
inactive and safe to handle
we wanted the samples to be able
to be used for sequencing and monitoring
of variants that might emerge
and we wanted it specific primers and
probes to be in regions of the genome
that were less likely to mutate than the
area selected by the cdc
so the journey we took was to develop
what we considered a better pcr assay
we put the cdc primers and probes
head-to-head against the assay that we
fine-tuned for development in saliva
for example using two different channels
and a pcr plate
we could put the cdc test in the sam
channel we could put the test we were
using
that interrogated the rna-dependent rna
polymerase gene
and the hex channel and we could put the
optimized human control gene in the cy5
channel and we could detect all of these
in the same well very efficiently
with complete
certainty about the signals
except that the cdc primers and probes
tended to give false positives at late
cycle numbers so we actually had to
remove those in order to improve the
specificity of the assay
we determine the limits of detection of
our assay using a multi-probe design in
the hex channel
we demonstrated its utility using 30
positive and negative samples that was
the initial
bar that you had to meet
for emergency use authorization by the
fda
we demonstrated the stability of the rna
across simulated transport extreme heat
extreme cold several days
this was a major issue for
nasopharyngeal swabs which were
collected in viral transport media
with delays approaching a week for those
samples to reach a testing lab there was
no control over the stability of the rna
in those tubes and often made it
impossible to obtain usable virus for
sequencing
we also had to demonstrate the
robustness of the sample to multiple
interfering substances that you might
find in the mouth
such as toothpaste mouthwash
even nasal spray or blood
and it passed all those tests
post approval we had to submit to a
blind sensitivity and specificity
analysis
and when we did that
using the swab that we had
utilized in prior tasks as joe mentioned
for the past decade
and other biomarker work
we achieved new york state authorization
initially in july of 2020
new york state doh approval for the
individual tests a month later the fda
eua a month after that
and the blind
post
eua
sensitivity and specificity
analysis showed that it was the best in
class of all saliva tests that had the
most sensitivity
it was also resistant to mutations
already by mid-2020 we were seeing
mutations creep up and make some of the
initial
primer and probe sites that the cdc had
targeted unreliable
during this approval process we also
worked a great deal on the pooled saliva
test we recognize that the testing need
might ramp up
we were not among those who thought this
pandemic would go away by april or may
in fact we anticipated correctly
what we were able to achieve
with the pooled saliva test was the
ability to pool up to 12 samples and
that received a key way from the fda as
well
and when we did so we didn't lose any
sensitivity versus the individual test
part of
the ingenuity behind the pull test
involves the use of the liquid that's in
the tube if you look at the swab in the
upper right
that liquid stabilizes the saliva that
is picked up in the highly absorbent
swab that's sticking up out of the top
of it
so we were able to sample that fluid in
a pooled fashion but retain the
individual swab itself
for
reflex testing when the pool is positive
that liquid
also makes handling the pool liquid
completely safe
in a laboratory environment
we showed that it completely inactivates
the viruses that we were able to test
as well as yeast and that's what you're
seeing example of
there's two strains of yeast that after
just a few minutes of contact with that
exact liquid
are unable to grow
on
their proper media
compared to how well they grow with just
water
another element of that liquid is that
it actually inactivates
rna cells that are in such high
abundance in the oral
cavity as well as the respiratory tract
and everyone knows these rna says
they're there they're actually part of
the immune response
in fact the cdc
control gene for the presence of the
humans
nucleic acid in their samples targets
the rna's p gene
so you need to inactivate rnases if
you're trying to track
rna viruses and this solution does it
so i mentioned we had no loss of
sensitivity in the pool test versus the
individual test what you're looking at
on the upper left of this slide
on the x-axis is the ct value the number
of cycles of threshold that it took to
detect a pool that was positive
following our pool processing
and in those pools it was determined
that a single positive individual
existed and that's what's plotted on the
y-axis
extremely high correlation
and
although there is a shift that you can
see on the upper right of one to two
cycles
the pool was always positive and that's
shown 90 pairs
of pools
many pools particularly when there was a
surge
would also show
an increase
in viral abundance which you could see
by fewer cycles to threshold that's the
pcr amplification plot at the bottom
so we could actually model the number of
positives that we expected to see based
on the study of many many pools
test sensitivity
is very critical
and
not losing sensitivity with the pool
test was critical for deploying this
test in a large scale
the most commonly used pcr tests
in the united states
is tests that were developed around the
cec primer and probe test or the cdc
test itself
or tests offered by
large laboratories commercial
laboratories
and those have a sensitivity that does
not
do any better than 18 000 copies of the
virus per
ml
and that includes the yale saliva direct
test for example
the test that we had developed was
determined in the blind sensitivity
testing
to have a sensitivity of at least
600 copies per ml ranking it among the
most sensitive of all
tests
if you're using one of the more common
tests
you can see on the y-axis
that you will miss
at least forty percent of positive cases
that's still better than rapid antigen
tests
you can see i've drawn an arrow there
indicating the sensitivity
the nominal sensitivity the copies per
ml
plotted for one particular widely used
rapid antigen test and that would be
expected to miss at least 60
missing positive cases certainly
contributed to the exponential rise in
undetected positivity around this
country
moreover it gave people who
misinterpreted a negative test result a
false sense of security that they could
go out
and not worry about spreading it
the pool testing is what sunni
challenged us to do
once they had seen our results
they asked us to
develop a means of distributing
performing
and delivering results from this test
every week to the entire
state university campus population
and this is the largest state university
system in the country
so the challenge was to be able to test
everyone on campus as often as possible
the basic overview of the process that
we developed is illustrated in this
slide
we would have students or faculty
use the individual swabs
and there's a set of 12 swabs maybe one
of those picked up virus you can see
with the red
swap tip
the lab would collect these slots create
a pool fluid from eloqua to those swabs
and the pull two would be
analyzed for the presence of the virus
if it was negative then all the
individuals who contributed swabs to the
pool were presumed negative
if it was positive we simply opened up
the individual tubes and subjected those
to individual testing
this was the system we implemented these
were clinical results
they were reported to new york state
department of health and the electronic
clinical laboratory reporting system
what we were able to achieve
was
not quite the gold standard
we had
much to strive for the gold standard
would be testing every day
and producing same-day results
if you could do that as shown in the
upper left of this slide you could
reduce
more than 95 of all the infectiousness
in a population
what was happening in this country
maybe people were going to providers
early in the pandemic and sometimes it
was taking a week for results to come
back
and sadly that was not removing
any of the infectiousness in the
population compared to simple
self-isolation
what we achieved with the pooled
roll out
statewide
we could return results
sometimes same day if it was a local
campus or then very next day
and we could test weekly
and it's estimated that we removed 60 to
70 percent of the population
we had
to scale this process up
and that was not trivial
as all the students rolled out to campus
that fall in 2020
we ramped up
our ability to perform the testing
we had approximately 40 people working
in the lab seven days a week
and we're running pcr and there's a look
inside the pcr lab
almost
100 hours a week doing all this testing
but by scaling up we were able to
process more than 30 000 samples a day
in a single laboratory
and that enabled us over the course
of that first semester and through the
early part of the
winter and spring
to perform nearly 2 million tests
statewide from more than 80 colleges and
universities including not only the suny
campus population
but at least 10 other private
institutions who sought out the test
it also enabled us
to scale the sequencing efforts
and
indeed
well
we were rolling out the tests in that
first fall of 2020
we were able to sequence more than 2 000
positive samples
we also developed
antibody testing and i'll mention a few
of those
highlights from that later on
our sequencing efforts
enabled us
to look at the appearance of mutations
across the genome in this virus and
that's what's shown here
the essentially the diversity of
mutations in different regions of the
sars co2 genome
across all the different genes that are
located there and i've written in the
name of the spike
protein gene which is so critical to
understanding the virus
and the nucleocapsid or n gene
and you'll note that
these have a higher density of mutations
than other regions of the genome
our pcr assay is approximately in the
middle of the virus genome which is not
targeted with high numbers of mutations
if the virus
is mutating in areas where the pcr tests
are designed to interrogate that could
be a problem in the sensitivity of the
test
i'll return to that point later
our efforts at sequencing
gained some insight from what we were
able to
understand looking at clinical samples
right at the beginning in march 2020
we were able to obtain saliva samples
from hospitalized patients with severe
covalent
and in that scenario we didn't have to
do any pcr target enrichment and what
you're looking at here are the all the
aligned reads across the genome from one
severely ill
source code two patient
and there was a depth of approximately
200 reeds across more than 99.7 percent
of the genome we would call that pretty
good coverage
but this was a patient who actually
didn't survive
so we needed something that could be
used when the virus
load was not
as high as that
we needed something that we can
implement
at scale
for 90 of the positive samples that we
could identify in clinical testing
we were funding all of this initial work
through suny
and our own campus initiatives because
of the importance that we recognized it
represented for public health
we later received funding from new york
state department of health to continue
this work
in order to
adopt such a scaled-up effort
we had to identify the best enrichment
pcr protocols and so we did a lot
of searching
we looked
and found the arctic vc protocol
using the sql flexwell method and that
seemed highly attractive to us because
of the scalability
it actually enabled us to implement low
moderate and even higher throughput
sequencing
as needed
and what you can see on the bottom of
this slide are the plots of daily cases
in blue and testing positivity
and gold across time throughout the
courses of pandemic
and clearly
when we adopted this sequencing
methodology we had no idea what was
coming
but what we've seen is it's been
invaluable for our efforts to keep track
of the sequencing demands that we were
faced with
the traditional method of implementing
the plex well
technology
is illustrated on the left of this slide
which involves using individual tubes
we made some modifications to that to
meet the sequencing throughput
needs that we had
so rather than prepping one
plate at a time
which you're seeing in the middle
a single plate gets reduced to one two
we found using
a 96 well
by petting device the gilson plate
master specifically
we could actually prep 12 plates at a
time
then we could purify 12
tubes at a time and you're looking at a
magnetic stand rack
magnetic
that can hold
six tubes on one side and six on the
other with the magnets visible for one
side and then the other
we could purify all of those at once and
take them to the next module the pool
bar coding module
which instead of being processed one
tube at a time
we found we could do three
pcr strips or up to half a plate at a
time
because we would do the purification
using plate-based magnetic beat
purification
and that enabled us to process
routinely during the peak surges
24 plates at a time
every week
and that's what we've been doing
through all of these late searches in
2021 and early 2022.
just a closer view if you look on the
first picture on the upper left
you can see the plate master is in a
position to pick up a whole plate of
tips
there's this 3x coating buffer
immediately above it
and we would go in
with a full rack of tips you can see in
the second picture pick up the coating
buffer
and move it over
to the sample barcode plate that comes
from sql
and we would add
that coding buffer directly to it with a
single push
then with the same tips
we go into the diluted cdna from the
arctic now v 4.1
protocol
pick that up and introduce that into the
sample barcoding plate and mix that 15
times so that's just an illustration of
how quickly we can load a plate and we
can literally
load eight to ten at a time
before the protocol
required by the sample barcoding method
finishes with the first incubation of
the very first plate
the pool barcode step
benefits from the magnetic
feed cleanup being done in plate format
and that's what you're seeing below
our initial sequencing performance
indicators were very strong and they
continued to be so
we typically would run two by 150
read lengths either on the next 500 and
certainly the next week 2000 as we
scaled up
and we would see more than 93 percent of
the reads past the filter
and we'd see a very high uniformity of
the percent
passing filter per index and that's
what's shown on this separate plot
in this particular case there were eight
plates for approximately 768 samples
including the negative controls
and you're looking at the representation
of all of those
which is going to be
less than a quarter of a percent if you
do the math
across
all of the reads that were found
so the sum of everything that you're
seeing there would be 1 1.0 or 100 of
the reads but individually you can see
very good balance
now intermittently if you're looking
really closely
you'll see
a gap
just short of 100 just short of 200 just
short of 300 for it that's the negative
control
and that indicates that water
resulted in no
sequence representation water would
should sail the pcr
and water should not be contaminated
during the plex-well methodology if it's
done correctly and that's what you're
seeing evidence of water does fail and
it comes up empty
we also were able to evaluate the
quality
and depth
of the coverage that was generated in
our higher throughput methodology
and evaluate that with regard to the
amount of virus that was present in the
sample initially and that's what you're
seeing in the lower plots
using next clade
to determine
whether a sequence was of high or
moderate
or poor quality
or plotting the incidence of those calls
against the cyclist's threshold
of the clinical test the pcr test that
was done initially
and the pcr test that used the rna which
we later sequenced
and you can see on the left lower plot
that there's a trend certainly
at or around
33 34 cycles
the probability
of
generating high moderate quality
genomic coverage
drops
compared to the probability of
generating poor coverage
and so we adopted initially a cutoff of
38 cycles
we later lowered that to 36
and finally with the demands of omicron
to 33 cycles
if you look in the lower right you can
see the
cycles to threshold cutoff value
plotted against the mean
or median sequencing coverage
for a set in this case of approximately
1700
sars code 2 sequences
and you'll note that
below
33 cycles there's a much greater
probability of getting
higher depth of coverage and that
certainly contributes to
greater likelihood of high to moderate
quality
of ascertainment or designation
by the next clade
so generally speaking that's our cut off
moving forward
we started looking at the diversity
the first four months of 2021 when we
were really ramping up the sequencing
and we observed some surprising trends
in new york state
it was actually
the new york variant that stood out as
the most abundant whereas the rest of
the country was experiencing an alpha
surge
the new york variant
is identified by the lineage b 0.1.526
the alpha originally designated the uk
was the b117
and clearly the race for new york
had begun
you can see on these plots we're going
to see a number of these what's plotted
on the x is the number of mutations
in the viral genome
and as a virus
acquires more and more mutations
it may diverge enough in the areas of
the genome that are mutating
that it forms a new branch so this is
essentially like an ancestral family
tree
and clearly
the iota
was emerging in our population but
interestingly the iota is very close to
the epsilon
so the new york and the california are
very close to each other on this
branch these tree branches if you will
so we didn't know which was going to
emerge
and we didn't know which one might
continue to diverge the most
these mutations
that are plotted or the number of which
is plotted in the last light are
important because they affect as you see
on the right of this slide
the ability of the host to respond
and the ability of antibodies and
treatments
to work
and many of these so-called variants of
interest like iota was share some of the
very same
mutations in the spike protein that are
considered high impact mutations and
that was a concern
this is a geo map of
the mutations
and the variants that we observed
most frequently in the first eight
months of 2021
and you can see
there is quite a bit of regional
diversity and this was unexpected
it was largely
two epicenters
where iota surged
in our testing data one was in the
northeast corner of new york state in
the upper part of the figure
and the purple slice of the pie
indicates all of the iota or new york
another
epicenter was actually in downstate
and these areas are separated by
hundreds of miles they are connected by
an interstate but i don't think the
viruses are hopping on that to travel
back and forth yet these two sites
mirrored each other quite a bit
other parts of the state you could see
clearly we're dealing primarily with
alpha that's indicated by the red slices
of the pie
and in the first eight months of 2021
toward the end of that summer
we're seeing the emergence of delta
and it's not everywhere but it's
creeping up in certain locations
this is a plot of the top 12 lineages
across time
in the first eight months of 2021 with
90 percent of positives sequenced
and so you can see as we go from left to
right along the bottom
clearly in the initial phases of the
pandemic
some of the
more ancestral
lineages the b1 b1.2
were struggling to get a foothold
in new york state iota took over
and it probably attenuated the expansion
of epsilon or the california variant it
was happening in other parts of the
country
those two together especially iota
likely held off alpha for a little while
but alpha definitely expanded
through late spring and into
summer
testing was reduced over the course of
the summer there were a lot fewer
students on campuses
but they came back they started to do
pre-return testing and that's when delta
definitely emerged in the late summer
once the students were back
this is what happens on the campuses the
next 1000 genomes showed this pattern
clear emergence of delta
you're seeing that at the top
and a marked reduction in anything else
a little bit of alpha remaining and some
mu
we also note
that there were more mutations occurring
in the delta lineage
what had started out as a strain that
perhaps had
30 plus mutations
was now
showing branches that were encroaching
on 50 or more
mutations this is a concern
the system that we had developed for
testing also enabled us to evaluate
vaccine efficacy
and
what we saw
initially in the first half million
tests
when you look in this table in the upper
part of the slide
backed up what the manufacturer claims
were for the different vaccines that had
become available
we did this evaluation
in early spring when approximately half
of that half million
students faculty mostly
had been vaccinated
and so it's a deep data set
and we're able to determine
in fact that the jnj vaccine did provide
protection
one shot
of an rna vaccine whether it was pfizer
modernity provided approximately the
same protection
and then two shots of moderna or fisa
provided
95
or 90
protection
and that supported the claims
but what we saw when we looked
at the
first 100 000 tests
that had
been performed
during that delta surge
was a clear reduction
in the efficacy
so j and j no longer provided any
significant protection
just 10
efficacy
and the efficacy of the moderna and the
pfizer full
vaccine as it was called or two shot
as it's more accurately called
had been reduced by 35 percent in each
case
we did see promising protection however
being provided by those who had received
a third shot a booster shot of one of
the rna vaccines
so why
this 35 reduction
waning immunity is certainly part of it
and we actually evaluated saliva
antibodies
iga antibodies igg antibodies igm
antibodies
they retract in our assay that we had
fine-tuned and deployed
and so what you're looking at in this
case in the upper right of this slide
is the levels of antibody in a pfizer
vaccinated population
that's the
mean and the 90 percent confidence
interval
illustrating where
people would expect their
their
iga igg and igm protection to be across
time
and clearly
two months after vaccination
is your peak protection and that period
of protection would extend
three or four months
but eventually you would drop
much lower and this delta surge was
coinciding with the reduction in
immunity
that the people who had been vaccinated
initially the beginning of the year
were showing
at the same time there's an increasing
number of delta
variant mutations going on
and we were able to observe that here
plotting the average number of amino
acid mutations
that were occurring in the sample data
across time
and
with this increase in mutations
clearly we were going from the iota
dominant
new york state landscape to the alpha
dominant
and then the delta dominant
by august but this line
if you follow it out
across time
would predict
that we may be at 60 or more mutations
by the end of the year
and this was a scary thought
because everyone had pandemic fatigue by
this point in fact everyone thought over
the summer of 2021 that we were done
until delta hit
and that
mentality
reminded me
of the movie jurassic park
and
there's a scene in jurassic park the
actor jeff goldblum
was quoted
when
he asked a question
about the dinosaurs not being able to
reproduce because they were all female
he questioned that
and said
life finds a way
you sure that's really going to be the
case and of course we all know the
dinosaurs had no problem reproducing
i think the virus is following suit
and continuing to find a way
to exist in the population and
increasing mutations is one way that it
can help do that
the prediction of finding 60 or more
mutations
seems to have been met
by the omicron
unanticipated
we had to expand testing and sequencing
demands just a few months ago
in order to meet volume needs
that
exceeded 10
of new york state's testing volume
if you exclude new york city and that's
what's shown
the gray line plots the percent and
that's continued
through this day
this is an enormous amount of testing
and an enormous amount of sequencing
that we were obligated to perform as a
follow-on and it wouldn't have been
possible to do
without adopting
a scalable technology like the sql
plexwell platform
we also looked at the first
indication of how protected people were
against the omicron that was emerging
and i'll point out the upper left of
this table
you can see that unvaccinated persons
and people that had
one shot or two shot they all have the
same percent positivity
and it wasn't until you get to the
boosted individuals
three vaccination shot recipients that
you saw a reduction in that
and indeed
as of now
there is no protection from two
vaccine shots against testing positives
there is protection against becoming
severely ill but it's harder to quantify
that in simple terms
positivity is what's shown here
so
currently three vaccine shots for a
booster does provide protection but it's
nowhere near
what
it was
the likely explanation definitely
reduced immunity of course pandemic
fatigue and less
social distancing measures less masking
but also increased mutations
in this slide you can now see the
emergence of omicron and the number of
mutations it has right at that 60 mark
and that was exactly predicted back in
the summer
delta
you can see is still found this is the
first week of january
during all the testing and sequencing
delta was still around and there seemed
to be two sets of deltas
some that had
a lower number of mutations and yet some
that continued to mutate
but didn't adopt the same virulence as
the omicron
and even among omicron we had some
samples showing up with far greater than
60.
here's some more reasons why mutations
matter
you can see the spike protein shown here
on the right of the slide and everywhere
there's a mutation it's indicated by a
colored vertical bar
mutations showing up in the spike gene
impact the ability
of antibodies developed in response
either to a prior infection or in
response to a vaccine
to prevent
post-cell infection
these mutations are compared to the
reference sequence but it is the
reference sequence that the vaccines
were raised again
you can easily appreciate how different
a delta
spike protein is and its pattern of
mutations there's three deltas on this
slide
compared to the omicrons
which dominate the rest
another reason
why mutations matter
is the appearance of mutations in pcr
primer sites
and indeed the delta strain
just indicated that the arrows have
mutations
in primer sites
that impact one of the assays widely
used in europe
and the china
cdcsa
but omicron has even more mutations
including mutations in the us cdc
primary probe set
three mutations in the chinese cdc
prompt set and the europe
group set
china does not need less tens of test
sensitivity at the moment
this could pose a major problem at
helping control
the positivity as they're now facing
their omicron crisis
as we look at february
we now see a complete elimination of
delta in the new york state testing
population
last time we detected delta it was the
first two weeks of february
we also see the emergence of the ba2
lineage of omicron
and that's become more
prominent later in february and
continues to be so now
and look at the sheer number of
mutations
that are popping up
in that ba2 compared to the ba1
we look at the next slide
on the upper part of the slide you're
seeing again the spike gene
and all of those the top two thirds
of those sequences
are from
the more common ba1 omicron lineage
but the bottom one
is the ba2
and there's between 9 and 11 very
consistent changes in the spike protein
compared to ba1 this is really a new
variant entirely
it's
not necessarily accurate to consider it
just a sub lineage or a substrate
because these mutations
could impact
infection that could impact
vaccine responsiveness in ways we don't
fully appreciate yet
and yet it's predicted to continue
changing
here is a plot just through january
and you can see the influx of the number
of amino acid mutations
and that curve and i don't show it
through february but it continues to
rise
the number of amino acid mutations
is rising
and clear evidence that it's going from
60 in the original ba1 to now
80 or more in the ba2
should underscore the importance of
continuing to monitor
what's happening with the spiral
sequence
so we can look at our state data
and this is
illustrated down here and re-evaluate
what these peaks likely meant
through our sequencing efforts
the initial
spike that we were seeing from the
pandemic when everyone thought it would
be over
soon then the iota and epsilon surges
the alpha surge
the delta surge and the omicron surge
fortunately the pcr test that we
developed has not been affected by any
consistent mutations and we don't see
any effect on the pcr cycle to threshold
and the ba2 the ba1
versus
delta or other strains
so we will continue to do our sequencing
analyses and monitor
as we go forward with no need to
necessarily modify the pcr test at this
time
but we do closely examine the pcr test
for other
trends and one of those trends that's
come up more and more now
is the occurrence of recurrent positives
what i'm showing you here on this slide
first
is the
test
and retest positivity of individuals who
are vaccinated or unvaccinated
and many people would get tested a
second time
they didn't trust the first result or
they want to monitor their positive
levels in order to get back to work as
soon as possible
and so what you're seeing here is a
trend for higher cycles to threshold
especially in the blue lines
in vaccinated persons the virus is being
eliminated so it takes more cycles to
show up
versus a more flat line
or a line in some cases that points
downward for individuals who were not
vaccinated and had trouble eliminating
the virus
so this re-testing recurrent positivity
during the first
clearly three weeks has reflects the
same infection
but what we start to see
looking out to three months
and then
nine twelve months later
are these groupings of individuals
whether or not they were vaccinated or
not previously they were all infected
previously
and they're getting the same viral load
there's no significant difference in the
cycles to threshold the second or the
third time that's happening
and this is now happening with omicron
we're seeing people
in march who actually were infected at
the beginning of january
or in late december
and they're coming in with the same
cycles to threshold the same viral those
that they had before
why is this
is it a failure to achieve an adequate
host response
and more mutations at the same time
we definitely wanted to gain more
insight on this
so i'm excited to share just a little
bit
of our data with regard to immune
profiling of the host response
now a word about
saliva
saliva isn't just harboring virus
saliva is a rich
antiviral
media that is designed to contain
antibodies
such as the iga
hemoglobin alpha secreted
by
cells around the salivary gland ducts
you can see in green all those cells
we also have ig gamma or igg secreting
cells the ones in red
and these are very important at
neutralizing virus so not surprisingly
if you quantify total amount of protein
you find in normal adult human saliva as
we did
in the lower left you find
immunoglobulins take up about 10 percent
of all the protein there
but
salivary gland ducts themselves
cells also express
important immune class molecules that
indicate they're involved in antigen
presentation and neutralization active
neutralization of the virus
and of course they express enzymes like
rnases that act on rna viruses
so this convinced us we should be
looking at saliva we should see if
there's host responses
and where we looked first was that rna
profiling and the same clinical samples
that we had tested and sequenced
and this was done on a total of 192
subjects
split into 12 groups of 16 matched for
gender
age
race and viral load
and it included unvaccinated persons
with each of the major strains of
interest
as well as fully vaccinated persons who
had breakthrough infections
and the very initial comparisons that
we'd made of everyone was to the
unvaccinated never infected persons
so i'm just going to share
two data slides and results on the
individual gene level
and
on the gene group level
in addition to comparing groups group to
group comparisons of everyone
to the unvaccinated controls we also
looked
for evidence of genes that had
significant correlations with viral vote
this is an example of some volcano plots
just showing you there were significant
changes in every one of the comparisons
just a few of those are shown here
including just being fully vaccinated
versus control
if you look at the overlap the common
changes
you can identify with
all of those variants
a set of genes that appears to be
viral infection specific
and i'm not showing you the gene symbols
on the plot in the lower middle of this
slide but this is about a dozen
different genes
and you can see it marked increase with
an infection in the blue line for all of
these genes
a blunted increase in the gray line for
people that received a vaccine but had
breakthrough infection
and a complete flat line the orange no
change in expression of these people who
receive just a vaccine
an example of the raw data is one of
those genes shown on the lower right
so breakthrough
with one shot breakthrough with two shot
breakthrough from a delta breakthrough
from an omicron
there's an increase
it's much greater than the control
vaccinated or control unvaccinated
persons that are very flat
and there's a market
even greater increase you can see in
people who had infection with one of the
main variants of interest
so we're excited about that we're just
scratching the surface and we expect to
do single cell sequencing possibly even
using some of the technology you heard
geology too
one last data slide when we look at the
genes
that were most correlated with viral
load i'm not showing you individual
genes but i'm just showing you the
pathways that are enriched in those
genes that had the highest
robust correlations
and in saliva it was very clear that
there's entire sets of genes that are
involved in host response
including
trying to inhibit viral genome
replication defense response to virus
these are the two
most enriched
most correlated
of those genes that do show strong
correlation with viral load so we have a
lot
to learn from saliva we can learn much
more than just the viral lineage there
much more than just the state of
post-immune response but actually
the viral infection response
so it was possible in our hands to have
a positive sustainable impact on public
health through regular-based saliva
testing i didn't share the numbers with
you but our pool testing approach and
the system that we rolled out resulted
in 10 times less campus cases than the
surrounding communities
we're able to take all of the positives
and do full genome sequencing
with the stabilized rna and it was
certainly facilitated by adopting the
scalable plexul approach
and
saliva itself has some interesting
opportunities for monitoring antibody
levels as well as evaluating the host
responses
clearly one of the lessons we've learned
the most is the virus has not been
mutated
with us
or with itself
so thanks for your attention i look
forward to any questions you have
and i would just thank
all of these individuals listed here
it was a team effort and there are many
teams working on this
thank you dr miller and dr middleton for
your informative presentation we will
now start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and we'll answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for
all right let's get started our first
question asks did you evaluate different
pool sizes for pool testing is there a
practical upper limit on effective
pooling batch size
thank you for the question
actually i have a slide that addresses
this
we can bring that one up
the
answer is
we did evaluate different pool sizes but
there are some excellent theoretical
guidelines that we followed in
evaluating those
you can see in this slide
there are
different numbers of samples you might
include in pools that depend really on
two principal factors one is the
positivity or the infection rate in an
area that's the first call and you can
see in those subtables
but the second is the variability
in
the positivity across pools
and
what that means is some pools will have
more than one positive person in them
if it's uniform and there's very low
variability
and that's what all the models assumed
up to this point
then you would choose pool sizes between
11 and 15 for example when your
positivity is between half and one
percent
and you'd achieve efficiency of
something close to seven which means
you're doing seven times less pcr
to identify all the positives in that
population
but in reality
pools don't have low variability they
tend to have moderate to high
variability
in
congregated living
situations and
so we did choose a pool size of 12 and
that was based on our best
estimates and it turned out to yield an
efficiency factor of around seven
as theoretically
modeled by john cohen and if anyone's
interested in further information i'll
refer you to
his paper you can see the citation for
that at the bottom
great thank you our next question here
asks what is the maximum number of
samples
are you able to get on an ilmn flow cell
during a sequencing run use
plex well sql
so alumina flow cells
have changed in their capacity
we use
the nexiq 2000 flow cells and when we
use the highest output the p3
flow cells we can run 24 plates at a
time
and achieve sufficient coverage
to be able to have a minimum of 50
read depth across 95 percent of the
genome in all of those
samples
great thank you
all right this next question asks how
did your lab adapt to your sequencing
efforts with the emergence of omicron
variants were there changes you need to
make to panels used
actually that's an excellent question
each time that new variants or new
mutations have arisen
it's caused
a lot of people to closely examine how
well the arctic
pcr primer pools are performing and
other pools that are used for sequencing
as well
and i can tell you that the arctic
v4
does not perform optimally but v 4.1
restores
that and so we have adapted as the
community
of sequencers
have adapted those protocols
great thank you
another question here asks do you ever
anticipate to see a decrease in the
number of mutations in the future
that's an excellent question
unfortunately i don't think mutations
go away
unless there's the incredible selection
power
present against the emergence of new
mutations and rna viruses are notorious
for just gaining more and more
mutations
but if some virus did emerge it happened
to have fewer mutations that had
selective advantage over other
more variable variants then we might see
that emerge
but it's it's hard to envision that
happening
thank you
looks like we have time for one more
question here and this last one asks
what do you see as other areas of high
potential future impact beyond covid for
saliva-based disease monitoring
so we've certainly been very interested
in looking at human diseases
and human conditions using saliva
monitoring
and it runs the gamut so we've done work
in concussion we've done work in autism
we've done work in parkinson's disease
and we've done work in other infectious
diseases besides just covet
and we're very encouraged by our work in
all of those areas that
indicate we can monitor what is present
in saliva whether it's the microbiome
or
inclusive viruses that we could
resequence if we so choose or if it's
the host that we're more interested in
and looking at things like the micro rna
or the messenger rna as we did in the
case of our covid work in particular
so
the
sky
might be the limit there are a lot of
different scenarios where you can
imagine saliva testing
to be utilized because it is so easy to
acquire
and if you stabilize the saliva it can
actually yield a great deal of
information for minimal investment
greatly well thank you again dr miller
and dr middleton for your time today in
your important research we would also
like to thank labrutz and our sponsor
sequel for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we do not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
lab roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time take care
everyone goodbye
you